ich habe drei kollegen von mir
ausgewählt welches mit dem eis ihrer
träume überraschen werden nämlich re wie
sally und drop ich habe sie alle drei
gefragt was ist euer lieblings eis und
ich werde mich nur einfach das
lieblingseis zubereiten sondern ich
werde das in der krassesten version ever
zubereiten erstmal vielen dank bei der
mir diese maschinen hier gelebt hat
bevor sie ein einziges mal selbst
genutzt hat und wir fangen an mit
cookies sind krimis wenn niemand
geringeren als rob dafür brauchen wir
all diese zutaten hier war alles
vorbereitet für meine kämpfe weiter die
scheiße ist das hier die sache auch noch
steif schlagen das heißt ja noch mehr
volumen es ist sehr schlecht geschaffen
dass wir schaffen was wir waren sogar so
gut vorbereitet dass wir zu viel für die
eismaschine gemacht haben dann haben wir
alles noch mal halbiert und fangen jetzt
an indem wir unsere sahne schlagen es
wird leichter so wenn die sahne steif
ist gehen wir sie kurz in den
kühlschrank dann statt mir dass eine
schüssel geben dort hinein die milch 100
milliliter sind das dann kommt das für
die kondensmilch das sind so circa 150
dann kommt dazu eine prise salz und ein
teelöffel vanille extrakt ich habe mich
selbst gewundert wie einfach das
eigentlich funktioniert eis zu machen
wir müssen jetzt diese zutaten einfach
einfach schön verkürzt und jetzt nehmen
jetzt auch schon wieder unsere saale aus
dem kühlschrank heben die langsam unter
deshalb heißt es ja natürlich auch
frieden ewigen sahne leute jetzt können
wir auch schon unsere cookies da hinein
kreml so paar schöne große stücke
einfach du mir sicher dass rob genau das
meinte als er gesagt hat cookies cream
aber große stücke müssen seine das hat
also diesen ben jerry's charakter wir
machen so ein bisschen reue donuts
prinzip also am ende wird das anrichten
nochmal ganz krank so und jetzt einfach
alles film miteinander verbinden und
unterheben zwei geheime zutaten die
termine im vorland müssen auch immer
rein 1 teelöffel gesamten und ein
esslöffel dextrose das bindemittel und
trägt auch dazu bei dass das eis noch
mal extra cremig wird das auch die
komponenten die man rein mix zum
beispiel die oreo kekse ihre form waren
und nicht irgendwie funky schiff machen
so häufig zumindest verstanden so dann
machen wir den ganzen hasen mal auf so
sieht das drin aus dass dreht sich die
ganze zeit und dann befüllen wir hier
unseren einer alleine wie schon so di
orio brösel so diese klassische cookies
cream farbe geben deckel drauf und das
braucht jetzt circa 20 so freuen hört
scheint es ist ein anderes geräusch 20
minuten sind vorbei und wir schauen uns
das ganze jetzt mal an
junge checks und das vor allem ist ein
sagt ja und der ice einfach von jetzt 8
und 88
eur a ha ja ja von mir auf
das übelste ihr seht auch die channels
für noch schön zusammen geblieben also
wirklich so unfassbar einfach nicht das
hier ist essbarer cookie dough daraus
machen wir kleine kügelchen und geben
die in unser eis hinein das ist selfmade
ist unterschiedliche größe wenn wir das
gemacht dann kommt über nacht oder
mindestens für eine stunde in den
gefrierschrank rocks cookies und krimis
ist im gefrierschrank jetzt machen wir
für sandy amarena kirsch natürlich ist
andy amarena kirsch rum ist drin amarena
kirsch mccanns handy glaube wir fangen
an genau wie gerade eben und schlagen
unsere sahnesteif das sind so 250
milliliter league endspiel wenn das
wieder so ist ab in den kühlschrank dann
schreib mir jetzt eine rührschüssel 30
milliliter rund 20 milliliter amarena
kirsch saft 100 milliliter milch 250
gramm joghurt dann 100 gramm amarena
kirschen die hacken geschimpfe du kleine
haken wir so auch nicht so ist das
perfekt
abhängige schlüssel jetzt wird das ganze
vermengt
wir können ja geil aus sahne
unterheben heute ist es zu einfach es
ist so einfach happy das ist so
unendlich einfach mal wird in die
kommentare ihr wusstet wie es gemacht
wird also ob jetzt mal so schritt für
schritt gesehen oder das wird schon
wieder so ein traum leute wir brauchen
wieder unseren behälter das ist schon
schlimm träger
decke
23 minuten 20 minuten sind und wir
gucken uns unser eis an die wieder sehr
cremig aus
das kommt einfach nur im gefrierschrank
sind spekulatius eis für die wir nehmen
200 milliliter milch geben sie mir einen
top 250 milliliter sahne einheit
teelöffel zimt und einen zimtstange und
las er jetzt mehr ist für zehn minuten
bei mittlerer hitze während sich das
hier jetzt nehmen wir uns eine
rührschüssel geben 80 gramm puderzucker
hinein und drei eigelbe das vermengen
jetzt zu einer masse krass wie schnell
der zucker aufgenommen wird also durch
erhitzen schnappen uns alles und
schütten ist durch einen siebten ein
behälter das nicht schon so unfassbar
intensiv ja es reicht jetzt sogar
weihnachten spätestens jetzt dürfen auch
wieder schoko-weihnachtsmänner verkauft
werden ist so das geben wir jetzt
langsam zu unser puderzucker eigelb
mischung hinzu
immer wenn so ein mini feld passiert als
eric die zeit seines lebens jetzt kannst
du mir nichts mehr haben wir eine schöne
cremige mischung trefft die eismasse die
muss jetzt aber erstmal abkühlen für 30
minuten
so wenn die masse raumtemperatur
erreicht hat können wir sie uns auch
schnappen und bereits ein film wichtig
ist dass wir auch hier wieder dextrose
und xanthan benutzen das habe ich beim
letzten mal vergessen zu zeigen aber
gerade hier bisschen mehr von dem
santana von bindemittel war ihr seht es
ist sehr flüssig raus mit dem guten
stück nicht alles auf einmal hinein und
nehmen auf den gesamten zimt noch mit
das wird super intensiv machen und nicht
wohl an unsere kekse kommen erst rein
wenn die masse schon cremig ist damit
sie einfach nicht noch so aufgeweicht
werden weil die lotus kekse weichen
sicher schnell auf 21 minuten umgehen
lassen dann kommen die lotus kekse dazu
und ich bin jetzt schon so gespannt den
drei und das eis schmecken wird aber ich
sag ehrlich ich glaube es wird sehr
lecker so spielzeit anzurichten sandy
ist als aller erstes dran und wir
schauen uns zunächst einmal unser eis an
hier ist es sieht gar nicht so falsch
aus leute ist ist auch mein erster
versuch es zu machen dementsprechend bin
ich sehr gespannt ob sich das überhaupt
da aus kugeln bilden lassen das scheint
auch gut zu funktionieren sagt wir
machen erstmal die erste kuh
ja erstmal kugelt aber wie gesagt leute
das war ja klar dass das jetzt nicht
alles denn es war ja klar dass es dazu
kommt jetzt pimpen wir das ganze mit
kranken topix
[Musik]
auch auf so edel aus hey max damit hätte
ja ganz richtig dass es auch so klar wie
crm geht's ja wir wollten das ding so
pimpen wie es irgendwie nur geht wir
haben schokosoße haben essbare schoko
becht ja ja wir haben vor allem
natürlich das eis komplett selbst
gemacht mein erstes selbst gemachtes eis
wo ich merke zweifel
okay was kommt jetzt richtig gut drauf
ist dann aber erst möglich gemacht
du musst mal schauen siehst du das
diese becher schmelzen aber ich habe die
heißen kirschen
erfüllt ich habe auch schon vorher zu
10x war klar dass wenn die sich ungefähr
das einzige nicht wo alkohol übrigens
gratis
was sagst du zu eis zumeist für
cremigkeit so schmeckte das eis richtig
cremig ja aber das eis hat eine komische
konsistenz wo könig sich nicht so als
ich auf ja aber trotzdem sehr lecker
also auf jeden fall nur normale zutaten
und soviel kann ich verraten
das ist ein bisschen bindemittel drin
vielleicht hat das gemacht aber die
kirschen schmecken richtig gut gekauft
okay wenn du dem eisner note geben
müssen 10.10.10 von ca trotz konsistenz
dann bin ich auch so sehen würde ich
sagen dann bleibt uns noch übrig rock
sein eis zu servieren cookies cream und
das machen wir jetzt nächstes eisbox
cookies cream puh das sieht jetzt schon
sehr cremig ausbeute das sieht sehr sehr
krise aus aber es ist auch ein sieg also
im prinzip alles gut wir haben hier
schokoladensauce orio cookies amicelli
und drei sorten subway cookies lasst uns
einrichten
[Musik]
hier ist es also dein cook ist ein krimi
es würde doch cookies ja es wurde eines
der zwei optionen und ja es war
zitroneneis und cookies kennt so cookies
ja natürlich cookies cream 1 quasi also
ich weiss nicht heißes cookies cream so
kenne ich okay also ich kenne weiß
vielen ist es dass cookies ist so ein
vanilleeis mit mit cookie stückchen ok
sehr gut
ich habe michelle subway
interessant kurios ich wir haben auch
cookie dough pieces
verarbeitet ich bin gespannt ich finde
sparen lässt du dich mal
ganz wo ich anfangen soll aber einfach
eine portion glück ist
ja damit er merkt man da spricht jetzt
gerade die expertise
helfen gerade hunderttausende szenarien
also die stückchen dann kommen schon mal
anders geld da ist jetzt ein cookie
dough stück
war nicht hängen an seinen lippen was
sagst du dein erster eindruck des
perversen
übels ich hatte so diesen rollen donuts
gedanken merkst du ich dachte mir so ich
mache aus und
so schmeckt es funktioniert ist
funktioniert also ok zu meiner cookies
eis expertise das ist überraschend gut
in dem sinne dieses klassische cookies
aus der eisdiele ja es sei ja und ist
was ganz anderes aber das hier mit
diesen doppelt so vielen stücken und
diesen verschiedenen stückchen was war
das kurze ist das braune kurze dauer und
ort auch okay aber euro auch im eis
farbe als ja im grunde das was sagst du
zu konsistenz vom eis es gefällt mir
okay also wie gesagt mir gefällt das
richtig krass dass so viel mais drin ist
ja kommt super schwierig bewertet erst
mal die hälfte auf mehr dann kann man
muss darüber nachdenken
es könnte wirklich nichts daran auch
setzen deswegen 19 das kann also es ist
halt wirklich fans neun von zehn von dir
schmeckt mir sehr was ich selbst mir
schon etwas besser sein könnte ist ich
finde es ist so es wird sehr schnell
sehr flüssig direkt aus dem kühlschrank
sonne also da kann dagegen mehr so in
diese perfekte eis konsistenz lassen
direkten danke danke danke dir für diese
als überraschung an diesem abend sehr
gern und dann sei da noch ein eis tester
übrig und zwar wieder fahren wir zola
wir sind auf einem dritten tester bei
ihr angekommen vor uns steht unser 10 10
- lotus kekse und noch mal fürs auge ist
das ganz richtig
[Musik]
so mein lieber hier ist ein ice ich war
sehr überrascht dass du zeit genommen
hast aber das soll ja ich habe in dem
bock davor über rock auf spekulation und
sind und so was ich weiß nicht wieso ich
bin so locker was haben sie haben das
september ne du bist du der mensch ja
jetzt auch schon so einen
adventskalender kauf ich habe heute zwei
studiogästen tatsächlich abwehr genau
richtig einmal ein von sdi und mit sechs
holz und wir haben die gestreckt absolut
ekelig ja soll ich alles gleichzeitig
machen ganz viele mag ist einfach nur
rein snacken sagen was gefühlt was wisst
ihr schmeckt und dann das ganze bewertet
sehr gehäuft jetzt hier auch die
c-junioren wir lassen uns nicht lumpen
wir haben uns vor wir haben wir wollen
das neue download der das eis sein du
baust über lecker new york sehr sehr
geil dass hier noch nur mit grün ist ja
was sagst du es ist sehr cremig ja das
ist sehr sehr fertig sondern ich finde
es sehr sehr geil muss ich ehrlich sagen
ich möchte mir sehr gut letztlich so ein
bisschen wie hartberg so gucke dauernd
weißt du was ich meine
was sagst du halle note braucht jetzt
nur bis zur 75
ich glaube das einzige was mich ein
bisschen loki stört ja sagt und ist doch
so krimis
sehr schwer ich glaube das lag an diese
pulverdinger die freien gemischt habe
aber nichtsdestotrotz geschmacklich fand
ich alle drei eissorten hammer leute ich
hab so klein gedanken in meinem
hinterkopf ich habe eigentlich bock die
ganzen eissorten noch mal zu machen zu
perfektioniert und dann vielleicht für
einen guten zweck mal zum eis wagen
durch die stadt zu brettern falls jedoch
auch lust habt schreibt es in die
kommentare
ich danke dir dass du getestet hast ich
werde das rausbringen kriegs 0 euro an
von jedem verkauften angebot an dich und
wir sind es beim nächsten video
wiederwahl